I'm speaking to mr.
Vin maloney who worked for the public works
on the sydney harbour bridge. What did
you do the mr maloney i was
a design engineer mainly on the approaches
to the bridge the approaches from
and to the bridge and then from the bridge
to when your station. The part that was
done by day labor the public work
supervising that's correct. And how long we
working the deed a period of six years.
Do you member of getting the job. I do as
a matter of fact i recently came over
from victoria for a holiday and i've had
a holiday ever since being thirty five years
with the public works and they're tied
for twenty what i'm having
a good time they're better god never
do you remember getting the job who
interviewed you was it terms to talk
about real. Now and fortunately they had
a great time for him and i think all his
staff were magnificent taught him and they
treated him so. I was interviewed by mr.
Gordon stuckey who was here today.
Gordon and i have had quite
a good yarn about what we did
in those days he finished up as
a consulting engineer and i met him out
of various occasions past history kenja
their public works at bathurst. Do you
remember any stories about when he worked on
the bridge. Well i don't know i've had so
many stories that are probably for his
time i don't think about
the whole lot but it's
a very enjoyable time and i can
assure you we're all worship dr.
Bradfield for what he was to us and what
he actually did he was our model in all
directions. Can you think of any funny
stories about him or any serious ones when
it. Talked about we would have various
areas in many respects but he used to pick
us for our particular jobs. One of the
main jobs is to pick on me for was to help
some of the photographers around mainly
taking movies of the work i was the only
one apparently in the office could handle
a tripod for that particular photographer.
Remember the photographers. I can't
recall but the main the
main photographer was
a kind and they went. He all his work.
I think has been taken over by the
institution of engineers astray. It was
robert bowden and there was bill brindle
here as well robert brown took mainly the
steals their other power. He took most of
the movies especially in detail. Didn't win
any of those movies are now i think the
institution of engineers have to how a lot
of them. I think you are much. I've got
a bit of noise going on
inside and there soon.